mesdames et messieurs 7 minutes 7
minutes ont suffit à plonger la
préfecture de police de paris dans un
des drames les plus douloureux de son
histoire et la france dans la stupeur et
l'incompréhension
ce jeudi dans les bureaux de la
direction du renseignement
là même où l'état traque terroriste et
criminel un agent administratif en poste
depuis plus de 15 ans un collègue
assassiné le major damien ernest le
gardien de la paix anthony lancelot
l'adjoint administratif
brice le mescam avant de s'en prendre à
la gardienne de la paix aurélia tri firo
qu'elle ait succombé à ses blessures
puis une adjointe administrative à son
tour dont les jours
heureusement ne sont plus en danger et
qui en cet instant est parmi nous sept
minutes 7 minutes ont suffi pour
arracher la vie à quatre des vôtres et
le tribut on est était plus lourd encore
si un gardien de la paix stagiaire ayant
rejoint le métier depuis seulement six
jours six jours n'avait fait preuve
d'une maîtrise et d'un courage hors
norme
en neutralisant l'assaillant après les
sommations requise
ces murs vibreront longtemps de l'écho
de ce geste comme il vibre encore de
l'engagement des héros d'août 44 qui ont
libéré paris comme ils vivent encore de
la présence des grands policiers et des
grands préfet qui ont foulé les pavés de
cette cour de cette glorieuse histoire
qui vous rend tous s'y fier d'appartenir
à cette institution républicaine kay la
préfecture de police de paris
si fiers ils l'étaient tous les quatre
si fier nous le sommes deux aujourd'hui
en ce moment de deuil
je m'incline au nom de toute la nation
devant la douleur des familles et des
proches de ceux qui sont tombés
j'ai une pensée affectueuse pour les
deux filles de damien ernest pour sa
compagne avec qui il nourrissait des
projets de mariage
après tant de vie commune pour les deux
jeunes fils d'anthony lancelot pour le
compagnon de brice le mescam pour le
compagnon et les deux jeunes fils
d'aurélia trifi raw pour les familles
collègues amis qui les ont tenté mais
la république sera toujours à vos côtés
elle est dans cette épreuve
elle le sera dans la durée je m'y engage
je n'oublierai jamais les heures passées
à vos côtés ce jeudi après midi quelques
instants après le drame les actes de
courage
les remords de certains les tristesses
la conscience aiguë le sens du devoir
déjà toujours la fraternité et la
solidarité qui rassemblait recettes
maison
quatre français sont tombés ce jeudi 3
octobre
et si l'émotion est si forte dans le
pays
à paris en province c'est parce que
chacun voit ton a eu un fils une fille
un père ou une mère un frère comme une
soeur un ou une amie
quatre policiers sont tombés ce jeudi 3
octobre il avait fait le choix de porter
l'uniforme de consacrer leur vie à
protéger les autres ils sont morts en
service au travail
comme avant que ceux qui depuis 2015 ont
été victimes du terrorisme islamiste
je suis venu parmi vous pour m'incliner
devant le sacrifice vaut quatre
collègues pour saluer notre héros pour
apporter le soutien de la nation à la
préfecture de police
si durement éprouvée je suis venu parmi
vous pour vous assurer que la lumière
sera faite
les interrogations lever les
responsabilités établies
la justice passera comme il se doit
je suis venu parmi vous enfin pour que
nous regardions la vérité implacable et
en tirions toutes les leçons pour
prendre devant vous l'engagement au nom
de l'état d'empêcher que se perpétue de
telles dérives
vos collègues sont tombés sous les coups
d'un islam dévoyé et porteur de mort qui
nous revient d'éradiquer et qu'un
individu imprégné d'une telle idéologie
puisse exercer dans le lieu où
précisément l'on traque les individus
dangereux est inconcevable inacceptable
face au terrorisme islamiste nous
mèneront le combat sans relâche les
fonctionnaires de notre préfecture de
police l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
de renseignement sont bien sûr une part
essentielle de la réponse 59 attentats
ont été déjoués grâce à eux
grâce à vous depuis maintenant six ans
et ce drame n'érode rien de la confiance
que j'ai en vous que la nation place en
vous en votre professionnalisme en votre
engagement
beaucoup a été fait durant toutes ces
dernières années pour mieux repérer la
menace améliorer les informations mieux
identifier et suivre les individus les
traquer partout en prison dans nos
services publics dans les entreprises
fermer des écoles dissoudre des
associations
c'est pourquoi aussi vos moyens humains
technologiques juridiques continueront
ils à être renforcée comme nous n'avons
cessé de le faire
loi après loi budget après budget nous
ne cesserons jamais de resserrer chaque
instant un peu plus les mailles du filet
sans que cette traque jamais
me remettre en cause les libertés de la
république pour chaque citoyen sans que
le combat ne divise la nation en voulant
faire perdre raison à chacun ce n'est en
aucun cas un combat contre une religion
mais bien contre son dévoiement et ce
qui conduit au terrorisme
attaquer la racine le terreau sur lequel
prospère le terrorisme islamiste et ses
vocations mortifère est tout aussi vital
professeurs fonctionnaires médecins
bénévoles associatifs sont unis partout
dans les lieux les plus sensibles de la
république pour prévenir détecter agir
contre la radicalisation c'est un
travail de longue haleine
toujours trop lents mais un travail là
aussi nécessaires dont nous ne céderons
rien bien au contraire
donner les moyens faire adopter des lois
agir à la racine
nous le faisons et le feront toujours le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisée
avec méthode et détermination
mais je veux aussi vous le dire avec
force aujourd'hui les institutions
seules ne suffiront pas
l'administration seul et tous les
services de l'état ne saurait venir à
bout de l'hydre islamiste
non c'est la nation toute entière qui
doit s'unir se mobilisent et agir nous
ne l'emporteront que si notre pays qui
est venu à bout de temps étant des
preuves dans l'histoire se lève pour
lutter contre cet islamisme souterrain
qui corrompt les enfants de france une
société de vigilance
voilà ce qu'il nous revient de bâtir la
vigilance et non le soupçon qui corrode
la vigilance
l' écoute attentif de l'autre
l'éveil raisonnable des consciences
c'est tout simplement savoir repérer à
l'école au travail dans les lieux de
culte près de chez soi les relâchements
les déviations
ces petits gestes qui signale d'un
éloignement avec les lois et les valeurs
de la république
une séparation cela commence par vous
forces de l'ordre fonctionnaires
serviteur de l'état
je sais combien vous saurez vous engager
pour repérer ces petits riens qui
deviennent de grandes tragédies l'état
se doit d'être exemplaire de se réarmer
aussi moralement par tous de mieux
formés chacun pour ainsi agir c'est un
changement profond dans l'état dans le
pays consistant à retrouver la sève des
valeurs républicaines
l'éveil qui les accompagnent l'exigence
qui les anime ne pas nous habituer
jamais trop souvent
nous avons pleuré par les prix des lois
puis sommes revenus au quotidien comme
si de rien n'était comme si ce quotidien
ne pouvait être habité lui par le pire
or c'est ce qui est advenu ici même ne
pas nous habituer
il nous revient de retrouver la force
des vertus républicaines qui toujours
l'ont emporté car ce qui se joue c'est
bien le combat de toute une nation
contre ceux qui veulent menotté la
liberté les femmes la civilité contre
ceux qui veulent diviser ses parts et
manipuler alors faisons bloc derrière
nos forces de l'ordre non seulement
lorsqu'elles sont meurtris par de tels
drames
mais lorsqu'elles agissent au quotidien
faisons bloc sans relâche contre
l'islamisme contre ces idéologie
mortifère qui ne reconnaissent ni nos
lois ni notre droit ni notre façon de
vivre
faisons bloc pour l'unité de la nation
en sachant rassembler tous les français
quelle que soit leur confession
quelles que soient leurs convictions
opposons à la haine l'intransigeance
républicaine à la terreur
l'irréductible esprit français de
résistance à l'obscurantisme l'amour de
la raison et son exigence faisons bloc
tous ici réunis nation toute entière
face au terrorisme islamiste
nous menons le combat nous mèneront le
combat
nous mènerons toujours le combat et à la
fin nous l'emporterons
car nous avons cette force d'âme
nous le faisons pour nos morts
nous le faisons pour nos enfants nous le
faisons au nom de la nation
vive la république vive la france
[Musique]